experts were certain we'd see a baby
boom during the pandemic but birth rates
were actually down in 2020 and now there
are some early signs that boom we were
expecting could happen next year denise
joins us now with today's health watch
with all the details denise yeah this is
an interesting one so we're closing in
now in 2021 wrapping up the year more
babies being born researchers say births
increased by three percent starting this
june now that may not sound like a lot
but it's the highest level of growth
we've seen since 2013 but here's where
the boom comes in analysts say there's
one telltale sign
pregnancy test sales those are way up
and they have spiked more than 10
a lot of research is showing us that
there's going to be a pregnancy boom in
2022. dr courtney gowen is an author
speaker and expert on prenatal and
pediatric care
nationwide sales a pregnancy test are
pointing to a millennial baby boom next
year gowin is already seeing a shift in
her patients members of that generation
are getting older and feeling more
prepared my patients have come in more
educated
more
empowered i would say in the birth
culture and financially i feel like
millennials are waiting a little bit
longer and they're getting on their feet
i feel like they're financially ready
many parents to be delayed having a baby
due to the pandemic with covid cases
dropping and vaccine rates growing
they're ready to welcome that bundle of
joy i think that they're starting to
want to live their life more and a lot
of millennials they see that as starting
a family
so this is certainly good news for the
economy because it suggests that
millennials are confident enough in
their financial future to have kids and
each additional child means a lot of
extra consumer spending because think
about this the average cost of raising a
child these days rating them all the way
to adulthood cost about
267 thousand dollars and change